we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's just a good
question about so-called Obama gate take
a look David I know the I
did ridiculous but with being put to the
test of specifics I don't have a whole
lot of answers
other than it takes more than just a a
president asking the FBI to investigate
a candidate for something to have you
need judges to approve warrants and and
stuff like that could you help me with
this please of course listen everything
you're saying is absolutely right but
the problem is you're allowing them to
put you on the defensive they are
asserting Barack Obama committed crimes
get a list of the crimes and the
supporting evidence and let's actually
figure it out don't feel as though you
now have to argue against this is like
you know Hey listen there are invisible
purple elephants in the room with me
right now but they don't disturb the air
they make no noise
what why why do you if I assert that why
is it you now that has to disprove it I
need to bring something to the table we
could say extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence apply whatever
metaphor or proverb or whatever you want
to it don't allow them to put you on the
defensive let's start with what are the
crimes that Barack Obama committed who
else committed the crimes let's look at
the uh the the the U.S uh code of law
and we'll go from there don't fall for
it otherwise we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today
we talked months ago about producer
Pat's pandemic displacement part one and
it was crazy today we will bring you the
incredible story I didn't even believe
it when Pat emailed me about it of
producer Pat's pandemic displacement
part two you will not believe what we
are going to tell you on today's bonus
show and also I have some prepping
updates that some of I know some of you
are going to laugh at me about
but I'm going to come clean I'm going to
admit the truth on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com or a patron at
patreon.com
davidpackman show